- DELTA, ALPHA, BRAVO.
REQUESTING DRONE SUPPORT.
I REPEAT.
DELTA, ALPHA, BRAVO.
REQUESTING AIR STRIKE.
[intense music]
♪ ♪
[modem tone]
- LET'S ROCK AND ROLL.
- WELCOME,
NEW DRONE PILOTS.
YOUR LIVES
AS YOU KNOW THEM
ARE ABOUT TO CHANGE.
- WHOA, BUDDY.
COME ON, MAN.
- THIS WILL TAKE A TOLL
ON YOUR BODIES AND YOUR MINDS.
YOUR FAMILIES
WILL NOT UNDERSTAND.
- SEE?
DADDY IS A REAL PILOT.
- I STILL DON'T GET IT.
- SOME OF YOU WILL NOT LAST
THE DURATION OF THIS OPERATION,
BUT SUCH IS THE COST
OF MODERN WARFARE.
- HEY, DID YOU HEAR
THAT RIVERA LEFT?
- NO.
- YEAH.
MEANS THAT CHAIR HAS OPENED UP,
THAT COMFY CHAIR OF HIS.
I WONDER
WHO'S GONNA GET IT.
- THOSE ARE MY DONUTS.
- I'VE EATEN THREE DONUTS
BY THE TIME YOU WAKE UP.
- THAT'S NOTHING
TO BE PROUD OF.
- SO YOU'RE
THE NEW OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST?
- SCARLET,
NICE TO MEET YOU.
- YEAH, I'VE GOT A PROBLEM
WITH MY CARPAL TUNNEL, I THINK.
- YOU'RE FINE.
- [sniffs]
[coughs] COOL.
- REPEAT! REPEAT!
[explosions]
I'M GETTING HIT
FROM EVERYWHERE, GUYS!
- MAYDAY, MAYDAY.
DOUG, COME IN.
- I'M COMING, I'M COMING.
I'M ALMOST THERE.
- WHAT'S YOUR 20, DOUG?
- STAY WITH ME,
I'M ALMOST THERE.
OKAY, I'M THERE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
- COFFEE. BLACK.
TWO CREAMS
AND A SUGAR.
HURRY UP, DOUG.
THESE DRONES
AREN'T GONNA FLY THEMSELVES.
- YOU THINK YOU CAN'T HANDLE IT,
YOU CAN STAND UP,
AND YOU CAN WALK OUT
RIGHT NOW.
Y--OKAY.
[dubstep music]
♪ ♪
- I GOT I.E.D.s,
EVERYTHING, GUYS!
[over intercom] EVERYWHERE!
THEY'RE COMING IN--
- DID YOU GO SEE THE NEW--
THE NEW ELVIS CIRQUE DU SOLEIL?
- OH,
I HEARD THAT'S LONG.
- OH.
- YEAH.